und wo ist denn deren flagge die müsste
eigentlich hier sagt man das ist unsere
berufung gehen weil ich nicht die miss
und einer von unserem team haben leider
gottes oder kann man die gegnerische
flagge
ich trag die flagge ich bin so eine art
fähig 30 lage die ganze zeit da muss es
geht sondern willkommen zu einer neuen
runde minecraft online spielen heute
gold gold gold
wir spielen heute capture the flag es
ist ein neuer spielmodus hierauf goma hd
punkt net im vip bereich mit dabei ist
der dom von at&t so zudem apps china ist
daraus was ich gerne auf meiner eigenen
welt zu ich bin so ein held link links
vor dem alten gangster in der
beschreibung
falls ihr noch nicht kein unbedingt
checken und ja wie kann man das kurz und
knackig erklären es gibt hier zwei teams
und hatte die flag diesen in dieser
runde jeweils vier spieler groß und
jedes team hat in der base die eigene
flagge und zwei briten gerade wenn wir
auch bei mir auch bei mir auch
aber das ist noch mal zwei andere
spieler und die sache ist die jedes team
hat in seiner berliner fleck und das
gegnerische team muss in die base
eindringen und da die flagge des gegners
erbeuten und die dann wieder zurück in
die eigene bringen dafür gibt es den
punkt und ja man hat eben diese gold
blöcke rechtsweg daraus gleich aber ich
würde den unterschied mit einer amtlich
gekickt mit meiner oma ein roter zwei
rote emma valetta nur 1 faust gerade das
ist ist sie oder kommt der zweite band
hatte ja gehört diese geräusche
hintergrund ist das mal sind die
geräusche die liga gemacht denn jemand
trägt day bieten graf ich meine mutter
nicht schön
ich habe an 18 dieser okay der s8 bücher
ist der swr mit der fackel gewesen fasst
ziemlich nice gerade dann auf 18 ja
richtigem namen aber ist dieser fakt
punkt um den namen bud gerufen
und dieser spielmodus eigentlich richtig
cool ich wollte mal was neues
ausprobieren leute so diese der letzten
feier ich sehr
und wenn mich nicht alles täuscht ist
davon die flanke von dem gegnerischen
team und ich haben uns jetzt die op ist
nicht die spd ist so genannten ist der
gegner bekommen auch die konkurrenz auf
ein bisschen regel die flagge erobern zu
wollen bevor können volk hat diesen
team-gold und es wird der erste punkt
wahrscheinlich wenn ich geld komme ich
hoffe ja ja ich bin liebt neben dem team
noch ein bauer hatte angegeben auf habe
ich bin zuletzt um gm wieder nicht aber
ich hab selber noch die flagge
gibt die flagge zu uns kommen kann ich
kann die leute kann ich glaub ich nicht
trocken ist polygamie haben punkt
gemacht und machen jetzt auf den punkt
so genau und sollte so ist das
spielprinzip nachricht gute sache aber
ich sag euch direkt wenn das alleine
spielt hat das gern ein sehr großes
potenzial aber jetzt habe ich noch dabei
und da kann man ein bisschen absprechen
das macht zusammen ja ich bin gerade auf
dem weg in die base von denen ich hätte
noch ein auslaufmodell sind bei uns die
bei uns zwei mal zwei mann
ich hab mich im redstone dass die flagge
ja ich habe mich lange okay ich volk
raten völker liebt den der unsere fall
hat die rechte flanke kommen ich kann
dir ist quasi links von deiner base oder
ob ich denn der beschluss gebe ich
dahinter hier neben mir okay ich habe
ständig erwischen vielleicht habe ich
ein kleid kein punkt als ob unsere
platte unsere flagge liegt einfach so
ein millimeter vor dem vor dem
checkpoint für dienste geben würde
bitte richtig punkte unsere flagge liegt
hier unsere vor gericht genau
amerikanischen team das so krass alter
und alter schwede liegt direkt davor
aber dies erzählt die können es erstmal
keine punkte holen bringt natürlich
kommt zu mir weil sie nicht alle unserer
patienten nämlich dass da irgendwie die
flagge während die diesen ihre eigenen
base ist ihre eigenen pcs und wo ist
denn deren flagge
die müsste eigentlich hier sehen wie
unsere flagge
also hier wird man das hier ist unsere
zusage von denen weil ich nicht die mich
und einer kompetenten haben ich glaube
irgendwie oder hat speck oder mittleres
das ist einfach so es liegt die frage
ist weg doch israels wieder bei uns aber
ein ach ja was hat sich eine mehrheit
von 11 von denen ich aber ich hatte
danach den hohlen mixa am mega ohne den
effekt und das aber postbus wert war wie
amazon.com pasta kinder das irgendwie
sehen aber leider gottes oder kann man
die gegnerische flagge
ich trag die flagge ich bin so nah
fähigkeit gerade die ganze zeit mein
gott wie kann man so dumm sein alter
deshalb ist aber auch nicht gemerkt
gerade so kann man ist ich muss noch
funken sprüht haben gangster die ganze
zeit haben gewonnen wir haben gewonnen
richtig geilen alter nicht mehr irgend
was war das für eine runde
ach du schreck richtige richtiger
richtiger brain fakt okay aber die
hatten fünf minuten gedauert deswegen
machen wir noch eine runde wird geschont
schauen dass es über war mal wieder eine
kurze so dass man wieder tim göhlert dem
kolleg dem kolleg dem kolleg oder coole
er klappt wir haben das modell wenn die
kohle am still und das ist ein anderer
web das ist die klarsten app zweimal
sechs und ich hoffe die runde wird
ähnlich knackige die daneben
ich hoffe diesmal habe ich keine
blockade das heißt sensationell
ich glaube die ganze zeit mit der fan
auf der bühne rum und ich merke nichts
als klatsche jemand ich nehme auf java
ich bin drüben bei gehen falls du mich
mainz gerade ja ich mache gerade auch
ein run über die linke flanke sowie alle
gefolgen ich hab du hast recht schützen
schützen
ist weil ich schütze dich wirklich
beschützen kann ich kann zu hause
ich hab mich okay ein harter kern ja
okay okay der seine kleine schwester
knüpft gerne denkt ich so war es los
hast du ja ich laufwerk ist natürlich
sehr gut sehr gut sehr gut weil das
läuft übrigens sollte drei punkte da hat
man gewonnen
so ist die regel erster punkt leben habe
ich wollte alles leben hat mich nochmal
angreifen kann man nicht auslassen
man schließt ja immer gern von sich
erwartet aber das war schon wieder über
die linke flanke zwei gegner bin ich
mache mit ein bisschen feuerschutz
ich bin durch ich bin ich durch okay ich
habe beide auseinandergenommen glaube
ich der kanadier kann ich mir so viel
gegeben haben ich bin leider gar nichts
ich kann richtig langsam laufen gerade
verschwunden
bitte doch auch mal drüber aber leute
ich muss ein echter wo bist du welche
allerdings los geht die richtige rücken
bekommt ein firmenschild und so weiter
ist kein safe punkt okay
er mag mich nicht so jeder ist an meinem
team will mich zu fragen sein braucht
man noch dann wird es für klima drei zu
null sieg
die kommentare was ihr von dem fünf
monate halten oder waschen zu uns ja ich
seh ich bin auf dem weg
ich habe den einfahrenden du den anderen
denn hier habe ich nämlich auch so was
mich den tod der frau sabine leitner
nicht erst alles sehr gut erzählt jetzt
jetzt machen wir mal massiven razzia
nichts zu 20 jährigen gefährdet mal oben
bisschen stehen kirchen den säckingen
drücken derzeit die längste zack weg mit
dem so man muss halt echt zwar auch mal
raus alles irgendwie oben
schlachtfleisch 1000 habe ich auch weg
so alles klar der matura okay dann
wollen wir mal zu zweit waschen und den
letzten punkt machen alles klar
davon bin ich doch dabei ich spiele
links hast du hast du deinen ganzen
stars mehr oder weniger okay die bases
komplett unterstützt wir machen jetzt
courage und hoffen dass du das 13 uhr
wollen
ok dann lauft ihr durch ich denke ich
mache den stecker mekka nach meckern
einen stecker nach mekka genau wobei
mekka ist in diesen tagen auf kritische
marke von st
ich bin direkt hinter ihr okay dass die
sache selbst alles kommt jetzt zum
versucht irgendwie mit kohl reinzulaufen
sneaker als nicht rein
saugut leute hat mir sehr gut gefallen
ja können wir können wir gerne noch mal
machen damit mehr viel spaß leute die
usa wir haben also ich würde mal sagen
ich finde den spielmodus eigentlich ganz
geil aber irgendwie mag ich ihn nicht
aber ich find ich geil was ich meine
also du findest neurotisch anziehend
aber nicht du magst du nicht im team
macht es mehr spaß einfach mal so ja
alleine alleine gehe ich mit einem
kopfschuss weil dann hat man mal hat
fünf unfähige mitspieler die in alle
himmelsrichtungen wenden sich nickend im
kreis drehen und dabei springen oder
nichts machen und da muss man die sache
alleine drehen gegen sechs und das hat
ja wie gesagt leute ich bin gespannt
schreibt eure meinung in die kommentare
wenn sich gefallen hat zeigt auch mit
dem like this davon leben youtube und
ernähren sich
ich glaube dass wir zulassen dass wir
beenden wie sie uns morgen wieder haut
rein machst checkt ob in der
beschreibung und